the Terminator films from their
inception always been it was an image
and scale of action that they've been
huge and you want that to be an
immersive experience where you Toby
takes you over there is nothing like the
imax format to put the audience of thing
it's one of the reasons why we love
working in that format the scope of what
we're sort of seeing a film like this
not just in the action you know there's
some like incredible landscapes the
details that we have it in all the
man-hours that went into the special
effects and have that turn into I'm at
it's huge it's absolutely epic on so
many levels when you elevate site to
that level what fans can get a more
indulgent experience
bigger the screen the better I mean you
know you're taken away you truly
transported on this night we take back
Wow and also to share it with an
audience I think that's a huge part of
it is uh seeing this movie not just the
action but also the humor I'll be back
what
there's so much opportunity to have that
kind of a visceral experience
there's no better way to see this movie
than an imax 3d
you